south park the fractured butthole is out
in october and if you're wondering what
you're in for
we've recorded this gameplay clip of the
most not safe for work thing we
encountered
during our recent gameplay session be
sure to check back to youtube for all
our preview coverage and
gamespot for everything else but for now
here's our encounter with some not so
friendly priests
just a reminder this one is absolutely
adults only watching
well hello new child i haven't seen you
before
but you come at a crucial time south
park is sliding into moral decline
someone's stealing our cats they're tp
houses
okay maybe it's not full on armageddon
yet but we do need a hero
not to make the hard sell but do you see
yourself as a good person
well i can understand the confusion but
there comes a time when we need to
choose our path
will you find jesus and take the
righteous path or maybe you'll walk the
middle way
let's not talk about the third
alternative i'm hoping you're part of
the solution not the problem
take the first step my child by entering
this meditative chamber
which will allow you to confront your
deepest fears
face your fears new child face your
fears
[Music]
your dad [ __ ] your mom
[Music]
oh hey i'm in your imagination just a
friendly catholic priest who would like
to get to
know you a little better yeah that's
right i'm totally in your imagination
too
about to give you a shoulder rub ever
imagine you'd feel something like this
let me adjust the lighting in here a bit
so we can get some visuals with that
oh i guess this one likes it rough no
complaints here
[Music]
[Music]
god's grace is totally filling me
quit playing hard to get
oh i like that
don't be shy there's no reason to hide
just let me get warmed up
oh oh my
oh who wants to hold hands and sing
kumbaya with me
[ __ ] such a cost back to you
oh my
huh don't you want to go to heaven with
me
almost ready to cover you in god's love
god's grace is totally filling me
with the devil venison to thin air
okay fine but next time we're definitely
playing grab-ass promise
don't be shy there's no reason to hide
you lose villains
[Music]
god damn it i can't put a child in a
dark room for two minutes without you
bastard showing up
well you're definitely going to hell now
get out of here that's not what the
queen spider says
i'll go say 10 mil harry's well gosh i
feel just awful about all that
tell you what a rabbi friend gave me
this macaroni picture
in times of trouble and tribulation use
it to call upon the prophet moses
good luck on your spiritual journey my
child